[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka spoilin king
and this episode were breaking down the
latest entry of the outsider the new HBO
show has a hell of a lot impact from it
and from the looks of it we're getting
to the bottom of the mystery that will
have you going loco down in El Coco Coco
that's terrible throughout this video
we're breaking down the ins and outs of
episode 4 the things you may have missed
as well as what could be happening in
the future there will be heavy spoilers
here so if you don't want anything
potentially ruin it then I highly
recommend that you turn off now we will
be talking about certain elements of the
book including what the outsider really
is so if you don't want to know anything
at all then it's probably best to turn
off now without the way I just want to
give a huge thank you for clicking this
video now let's get into our breakdown
of the outsider
okay so episode 4 finally starts teasing
as to what's really going on and even
gives the creature a name the legendary
El cuckoo in folklore
this is a Spanish boogeyman that is
sometimes referred to as either Coco
cuckoo Coolio el Coco yeah and the
creature has existed for centuries
primarily the legend is used by parents
to discourage children from misbehaving
and this sort of warning basically
terrifies them out of being naughty I
wish my parents had had done that
instead of making me play on the
motorway but yeah whatever
in the outsider el Coco is sort of a
vampire that can mimic someone's
appearance through taking their DNA and
this is how it was able to appear as
both the convict and Terry Maitland the
outsider is similar to penny wise in
several ways as it can shape-shift and
it also feeds on emotion the outsider is
even referred to as it at one point and
there are a lot of striking similarities
however where is penny wise fed on fear
at the outsider feeds on grief like the
killer Klown al cuoco hunts children and
eats them and this is a big aesthetic of
the show however here it also attacks
adults as well in folklore the creature
can take the form of a shadow and it
stalks and watches its price sometimes
for
before attacking this motif carries
across in the opening and we watches the
inmate from last week has breakfast with
a woman this day pops up later in the
episode once more and is of high
significance in piecing together the
timeline we watch the convict here and
you really get the feeling that
something is watching him and the open
air is masterfully directed to make the
audience member feel like a wire or
rather the outsider that is spying on
the tube it turns out that there's a lot
going on in the scene as we discover and
there's brilliant looks over the
shoulders and one through a window that
really gives you a feeling that the
character is being followed it turns out
to be the day rather than someone
watching them for this theme is repeated
throughout the entry and later we see
Holly following a hospital worker in
order to get results Jack to stalks a
deer while hunting a restaurant Goa
lashes outta glory Maitland after
peering at her and there is a repetition
of this throughout a lot of the scenes
in the present we pick up with Anderson
hearing some results from Holly's
investigation she has unearthed the
identity of the now deceased prisoner
and is slowly piecing it all together
his name was Heath Hofstadter and Holly
has tied him to the care home where
Terry Maitland's father lives as we know
from episode 2 when visiting this
hospital Terry gained a cut and using
his DNA the outsider was able to track
him across the country and then begin
its killing spree clearly the outside
was masquerading as the nurse in the
care home and killed a couple of girls
then realized it needed to move on and
chose Terry as its new face Holly was
refused access to see Terry's father
last time and similar to the outsider
she follows the nurse that we mentioned
earlier the nurse reveals that though
Hofstede is DNA and fingerprints were
found all over his apparent victims she
just can't believe it was him when
creating the book Stephen King wanted to
paint out the duality of serial killers
and this is paid lip-service here Holly
says that killers are often able to
blend in with society and this is how
the nurse didn't sense anything wrong
Kings original work stated that in some
ways Ted Bundy was a vampire and he
would appear like a normal person on the
surface all whilst having a thirst for
blood beneath it it's a really strong
psychological study and even show cases
that are myths
vampires werewolves and so on all have
filling in real life perhaps centuries
ago there were psychopaths who used to
drink blood and cannibalize people and
this has become the foundation of our
myths and legends this duality - pops up
at several points with a reporter
attempting to sneak into the Maitland's
home under the guise of being a live-in
nanny it's also reflected through
Hofstetter who appeared to have a double
side to him clearly something was going
on and the nurse even states at
Hofstetter came in on a vacation day and
that he didn't seem to recognize her he
also discussed the cut and we finally
get confirmation that Hofstetter was the
one who caused it similar to the Terry
case Hofstede I had an airtight alibi
that placed him at another location but
still he was arrested finally we have
answers to it and now know for definite
that the outsider posed as the nurse
went in on his day off
took Terry's blood and then followed him
across the country when analyzing the
CCTV later on the missing scratch on
Terry's hand is something that Alison
uses to pretty much clear the character
and it's a big piece of evidence in the
case
we learned that Terry scratched the arm
of the strip club bouncer and it could
highlight that in the upcoming episodes
he will try and take the appearance of
the character in order to carry out a
crime Jessa did say that when the
outsider appeared in a room that he did
see more muscley the second time and
though we initially thought that this
was Jack it could indeed be this
character speaking of Jack we cut to him
hunting and his rash has become even
more infected we see throughout the
episode that his mental state begins to
unravel even further the outsider and
the character will eventually end up
forming an alliance with one another in
order to try and kill Anderson and
clearly the fact that the character only
seems at ease when he's hunting will
help the shadowy creature sway him into
forming a union the outsider has likely
given Jack cancer and similar to the
source material I think that it will say
that it can cure him in exchange for
killing Anderson Holly eventually gets
to be a maitland but and due to his
dementia he's pretty incomprehensible we
did say last week that we had a theory
that the outsider could have been
masquerading as him - and this is why
seem nonsensical however this confirms
that he does indeed have the disease the
other majority of what he says doesn't
make sense
he at least does get one message out
namely that it wasn't Terry and that the
outsider fooled them all Holly meets up
with a security guard from last week and
he agrees to look deeper into what
happened in exchange for a date with her
weirdly Holly says yes I guess he wasn't
that creepy enough last time and we
discovered that he has the strength of
10 men because his heart is pure are you
gonna hear that that's the sound of a
million people stealing that line for
their tinder bio through him we learn
that because of the investigation the
Hofstadter's have been left incomplete
rune Hofstede his brother was ruled out
of the investigation but he ended up
overdosing himself and the mother of the
family drove herself into a telephone
pole the murdered girl's grandfather
suffered a stroke and the mother tried
to poison herself and he says that it
was like a plague we've already seen
something similar happening in the
maitland case after the death of Franky
Peterson's brother ended up killing
Maitland and died during this and father
Maitland also attempted suicide
so yeah fun for all the family after a
day goes well Holly goes back to Angela
and asks if Hofstetter went anywhere out
of town before the murders she says that
he went to New York and has a postcard
to prove this and that whilst he was
there he met a girl Holly begins
researching New York crime reports for
the time and Hofstetter was in the area
and she pulls up a child murder this was
committed by Maria Kanellis
who we saw on a date with hofstadter in
the beginning of the episode like a
virus the outsider has been spreading
from person to person area to area and
we finally have a more conclusive
timeline so from what we know the
outsider poses Maria went on a date with
Hofstetter took his appearance stalked
him across the country posed the same
cut Terry took his DNA and then followed
him across the country too unlike Terry
and Hoff seda though
Maria is still alive and in prison I
guess I guess women are just nicer
inmates apparently but Holly visits her
and begins to unearth the truth Maria
says that she would never hurt a child
and completely protests her innocence
saying that she never met or saw the
victim Maria doesn't really recognize
Hofstetter and says that she didn't meet
the character for breakfast she seems
like she doesn't know what's going on
and we learned that she's also had a
wave of
tragedy hit a family as the grandfather
of the child that she apparently
murdered shot and killed her father and
uncle she says that she knows who's
responsible but that if anyone found out
she thought this then they'd send her to
a nuthouse it's here that we begin to
learn what the outsider looks like and
how it operates
Anderson visits the boy that gave the
information on the stolen banner the
carrot he used and Hawley visits a woman
who knows the ins and outs of the legend
he states that all the old cultures have
a bad habit of turning truth into fairy
tales when we tell our children about El
cuckoo we say if you misbehave it will
take you away and eat you however as we
see in the show this isn't the case and
the woman say is that it simply takes
what it wants but then feeds on the
grief of the family and in meal terms
the child is said to be the main course
and the family's despair the desert this
is why the creature hasn't left the area
yet and why it's still lingers around
the Petersons and Maitland's the episode
closes with a look at the outsider and
this is the being that we've seen
following the crime scenes throughout
the series Holly does what any normal
person would do and Google's it tried to
get to the bottom of it and we are now
well aware that something horrible is
going on going forward now that we have
all of the pieces in place a thing that
the investigation will slowly start to
wrap up however it won't be easy
convincing Anderson last episode he said
he disliked things that weren't rational
and in the source material Holly has a
hard time convincing him that something
sinister is going on here eventually she
manages to and they track the creature
to a cave but I don't want to get too
spoilery just yet though because
obviously some people haven't read the
book and once some surprise is still but
there is a lot going on here that will
be unearthed over the next couple of
weeks it looks like Jack and the
partnership with the character will be
formed and he will try and get on the
inside of the investigation in order to
feedback info to the antagonist there's
a lot going on and I'm very hyped about
the return for the series next week this
has really made me want to revisit the
original work as I did find it a bit meh
but now seeing it's sort of remade with
the correct setup in place and so on I'm
finding it a lot more enjoyable and less
disorientating the outsider is awesome
and yeah I'm hyped
what's gonna happen next now obviously
I'd love to hear your thoughts on the
outsider and what you think will be
happening in the future comment below
and let me know and if you enjoyed this
video then please give it a thumbs up
that makes you check out our breakdown
of this weekend's are the big release at
the turning which is gonna be linked
after this we go over the movies insane
ending and give our thoughts on it so
it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more if you want to
support the channel from as little as 99
cents a month then please click the join
button below
we massively appreciate it and it goes a
long long way you get access to content
early and can also suggest video topics
and breakdowns if you want to come chat
to us after the show either follow us at
definition whitey or click the discord
link in the description below I also
just wanna let you know we're giving
away a free copy of dr. sleep to one
random subscriber and all you have to do
to be in with a chance of winning is
like the video subscribe to the channel
and leave your thoughts on the outside
or in the comments section below but
when it's gonna be chosen at random on
the 15th of February in the cell be
shipped out from the end whoever gets
the prize so best of luck to everyone
who takes part this is a channel for
people who are never missing television
so if that's the kind of thing you like
you need to subscribe to definition
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this you've been the best and I'll
see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you
[Music]